[Music]
chuck i do a lot of a fair amount of
reading of history i love
looking at how we used to think about
things
and how the advance of science and
technology
modifies improves supplants
whole words whole concepts that
just become obsolete
yeah like i think our parents might have
been the generation that might have
still called their refrigerator an ice
box
which because it was an actual ice box
literal ice box
you know the iceman would come in fact
my mother gets the ice here
ice cold ice
is how cold it is it's ice cold
and so chuck uh where was the
the
space within the box where they put the
ice
uh hopefully up top since cold air falls
exactly cold air fall chuck you you're
thermodynamically fluent i love you man
okay and it would have a mechanism where
it melted and you'd replace the pan at
the bottom where the water melted okay
so
then we have then we don't need ice for
it anymore because we perfect
refrigerators and it orphans some
people's vocabulary
and but that's fine i don't think anyone
under 60 calls it an icebox anymore so i
i'm i
i find that fun to track yeah vocabulary
the evolution of vocabulary in the face
of the progress of science and
technology you just reminded me of my
great grandmother and i'm just having a
fond memory right now because she lived
until i was
30
and she was born
in 1901
[Music]
and used to routinely tell me about
the iceman
and the fishmonger
and the
milkman
that all these people came around and by
the way
on horse-drawn carriage so that's the
stuff you didn't get from the market
right somebody came by and you got it
outside your door trust me since it was
perishable or it would melt right
exactly they couldn't just leave it at
the market hoping you'd come by and get
it right exactly right so
so
we go from horses
which you know we built civilization on
the back of horses we also fought wars
on the backs of horses and they never
got a thank you they never got me no
there's some horse memorials in the
world get out the to the war horses yes
i would speak with my sister about that
also many a war statue are the soldiers
on a horse so
um this is the horses are a fundamental
part of that but you're right i don't
think anyone told the horses before they
went to the battle that they'd be shot
at i'm pretty sure that was not a
they're not they wouldn't buck every
soldier
uh so we use forces up until
like the car is invented right right so
um
carl benz
sort of makes a really good version of
an internal combustion engine and
then we're off to the races
uh so so then what happens to the horse
well the horse rapidly disappears
especially from urban centers and then
basically from all of civilization much
later on farms i think but eventually
they would be replaced with tractors
okay right
so
what is the power of a horse
well i don't know but let's just call it
one horsepower okay so now you have a
car
and what is someone who rode horses all
their life call a car
a horse-drawn carriage without a horse
a horseless carriage a horseless
carriage okay
because that's the reference frame
you're using to identify so now you say
how powerful is the engine
we don't have any way to think about the
power of the engine other than in
reference to horses
so car engines started getting measured
in horsepower that makes sense
horsepower
okay so one horsepower so i know that's
like what like my horse right two
horsepower hey oh i got a pretty nice
carrots going on you gotta get carriage
going off yeah horsepower oh four horses
this is like cinderella no and six
horsepower it's been here
okay so
so
so there you have it now so power
once we all became metrified
uh you you can think of it in terms of
watts
so
uh one horsepower
uh equals about 750 watts okay
all right and because power doesn't have
to be how fast you're moving it's what
is the rate that you are consuming
energy so
in the old days hair dryers would be up
around that many watts right now and
they put it they they put it on a hair
dryer still oh
no watch they don't put horsepower on it
no the watts yeah yes definitely put
watts on it yeah but i'm saying but
generally you see horsepower on on
things like that go into motion or
in some cases i've seen
horsepower on on lawn mowers
on
motorcycles yes things that have sort of
engines because that's where the deepest
routes are traceable to when horses did
that work
that's all i'm saying okay so now
we are left with the completely absurd
completely
absurd statement
in nasa press releases
of how many horsepower the shuttle
rocket engines are oh man i love that
okay
oh man it's like souped up santa claus
2 000 horses flying into the sky
so
so you have nasa's press releases saying
the shuttle main engine produces 37
million horsepower oh my god
okay okay that's like that and so you
say that's powerful but
it is completely meaningless right
because because there are not 37 million
horses
anywhere
you will not find 37 million horses
probably on earth
so let alone all together just hanging
out
at kennedy space center right exactly so
now let's just say you could strap them
together right
no matter how clever is your strapping
your 37 million horsepower
is not gonna
if it's actually made of horses it's not
going to put you into orbit
right horses are not going to ascend
from earth and go into orbit around
earth however it is kind of cool to
start every space mission with five four
three two yeah
[Laughter]
gentlemen start your horses exactly
so we we didn't have a term
that comes to us from cars
that we need to then apply to apply to
rockets it would have been nice if we
had car power right right leave horses
behind now we have car so what's car
power let's say 100 horsepower is now
one car power let's say
all right then we could talk about
rockets and car power if we're going to
be one generation behind
i would have been okay with that
but no
they kept referencing horses
which i personally i think is completely
absurd and like i say now since
horsepower is just a matter of power and
so are watts and we all in the usa we're
all watt fluent all right um we could
just use watts kilowatts that sort of
thing okay there was a similar challenge
when
we detonated the first
atomic bomb
yeah right so is there a unit of energy
to talk about atomic bombs no because no
one ever made one before so let me guess
we now use exploding horses
[Laughter]
so so we looked back and said what is
the biggest explosion that we had before
oh dynamite a stick of dynamite okay
and dynamite is tnt
and tnt by the way
discovered by alfred nobel
got quite wealthy on it from it and then
created a fund
to reward
science and peaceful applications of it
especially with regard to medicine so
so tnt
a stick of tnt dynamite was the biggest
explosion we had so now we have an even
bigger explosion and so atomic bombs
were measured with respect to how many
tons of tnt it would be wow okay
so
the two bombs dropped in japan in
warfare
by the united states
each of those was between 10 and 20
kilotons
of tnt
10
10 20 000 tons
kilo tons okay that's crazy so that's a
fission bomb that takes uranium and
plutonium big atoms splits them into two
lighter atoms but those two lighter
atoms when you add them back you don't
get to the original atom there's extra
energy that got converted into the bomb
okay that's it
all right so
we would
develop an even more potent nuclear
weapon called the hydrogen bomb
which comes from fusing hydrogen atoms
together to make helium so you take four
hydrogen atoms you get a helium atom and
you have you started out with more mass
then you ended up where did the mass go
became energy energy equals mc squared
all right wow so
mild hydrogen bombs
are a thousand times more powerful than
your atom bombs
wow so we don't speak of them in terms
of kilotons we speak of them in terms of
megatons
nice 10 megatons 50 megatons mega as in
as in million right okay
so once again
we have these devastatingly powerful
weapons
uh and we're referencing their power
by something alfred nobel invented a
century earlier
wow
and so to me that's the same as well i
mean not identically the same but it's
it's it's linguistically the same as
calling a refrigerator in an ice box
right you talking about the power of
your car in horsepower right
right and we're still there it's still
measured in megaton they're still
measuring megaton is there anything
bigger than a hydrogen bomb
um
not that well a supernova
is is pretty big but we we just measure
those in in ergs with a power very high
power yeah we stopped finding words for
it we just said let's just go back to
any any unit of energy and stick in
there and stick it there stick it there
right we're not we're not we're not
measuring supernova in terms of
horsepower
right right this is not this is not
happening
you know what would be good
if we measured it this would blend pop
culture with science if we measured it
in
death star power
yes the power it takes to completely
obliterate a planet
we can calculate what that is oh my god
and then our hydrogen bombs would be
it's only one millionth a death star
right that's pretty cool and then it
becomes small rather than large exactly
yeah but yeah you can calculate exactly
how much energy it takes to completely
obliterate a planet right and by the way
in star wars the force awakens where
they have the new and improved death
star they can kill all the planets of
the entire solar system right and you
know where it got its energy from
where
okay it sucks the energy out of a nearby
star oh the star okay so it goes to a
star sucks out all the energy contains
it and then
dishes it out and take out a whole solar
system all at once so that's badass
right that is pretty badass except if
you actually add up all the energy of a
star
it could kill a thousand planets not
just
oh wow they didn't do their math because
then the the the dark force the dark
side would have been way more powerful
than anything portrayed in that movie
you know what we should do a show and i
don't want to offend anybody because i'm
a huge star wars fan
but
over the years i've heard you say many
many things
star wars gets hold back that they get
it and that they get totally wrong we
should do a show called star wars is
stupid
no we said it'd be awesome
i mean it doesn't mean that we don't
like it it just means like look here's
all the bad science that you find in
star wars i mean like
it's a smooth rolling metal spherical
ball right and somehow it's not sliding
uncontrollably on sand um not only sand
but on waxed floors like a bowling ball
dude that'll be a great show star wars
how to cut your viewership in half
all right so there you have it just sort
of orphaned vocabulary yes as time moves
on
and yeah it's just how culture embraces
it or not
pretty still want to think about it all
right once again good stuff good stuff
chuck always good to have you there
neil degrasse tyson for star talk keep
looking up
[Music]